[Music]
hi I'm Anika I'm from mango solutions
I'm really looking forward to joining
you for the our studio conference we're
with Winston Chang I'll be teaching the
intermediate SHINee workshop this cast
is for people who are really already
building SHINee applications many of us
have got the the groundwork we can build
a really simple application that that
produces simple graphics visualizations
outputs for reporting but to really have
an impact in our organizations we need
to take that a step further and make our
apps really interactive really usable
for other people and that's what we're
really looking to teach her in this
class so we're going to take you from
those basics and really help you to
understand how shiny works how you can
work on techniques to improve the user
interface and actually how you can start
to modularize your applications so that
they're much easier to maintain easier
to manage in production settings so that
you can really start to roll them out
across your businesses so if you are
already using SHINee and you want to
start to get more from your applications
I'd really encourage you to take a look
on there the conference website where
you can read the full description of my
workshop and I really look forward to
seeing you at the conference
[Music]
you